hello everyone this game well features
one of the most unusual mating pictures
I've ever seen and while I really enjoy
it so so maybe you will as well the game
was played in 2005 it was the Norwegian
championship Magnus Carlsen won this
event with seven out of nine points and
Carlson was 14 years old at the time
he's playing against a Norwegian
international master at like growing if
that is how it's pronounced although he
wasn't an international master at the
time this game was played he won the
title three years after the game but
nevertheless a very strong player
Carlson has the white pieces and he
plays Knight to f3 his opponent responds
with d5 we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 and
c6 the Slav defense Knight to c3 and
east six transposing to the semi Slav
Bishop to g5 h6 Bishop to h4 and Queen
to b6 eyeing this me to pawn Queen to c2
Carlsen defends it and we have nice to
e4
we have III preparing to dwell doe I
square Bishop Bishop to b4 now pinning
the knight on c3 and Bishop to d3
attacking d4 Knight Queen to a5 adding
more pressure to this c3 Knight and cost
and simply castles we have Knight
captures on c3 be captures on c3 and
Bishop captures on c3 and the Carson is
down upon but this position is known to
be quite advantageous for white rook the
b1 is played and now D captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and Bishop to b4
this rook is really preventing black to
develop his Queen side and while this
bishop has to has to get away from c3
with before and then get back into the
game maybe with Bishop to b6 or Bishop
to e7 depending and what where it will
be more useful across some plays Knight
to e5 and Bishop to d6
f4 cementing that knight on e5
we need to c7 and the Carson place Queen
to e4
for centralizing move this is a very
nice square for the Queen and while here
black could probably castle and it would
be well it would be playable for him
although even if black castles here
white would still get the initiative I
will get back to this position later but
a constant opponent played b6 in this
position and he allows Carlsen well a
fierce attack him Paulson played Knight
captures on f7 a nice sacrifice but you
know what are you gonna do
should you captured with your king if
King captures this Knight and f7 then f5
and you can't recapture the bishop is
painting this pawn your position is
completely falling apart and after
Knight captures on f7 you can't really
decline the sacrifice with rook to if
rope to f8 this losses to Knight
captures on d6 with Czech Queen captures
and Queen to g6 King 37 Queen captures
on g6 King has to go back to e8 and now
Bishop to b3 rook to f7 for example and
Bishop to g6 pinning the rook and black
is falling apart here so after Knight
captures on f7 his opponent played Queen
captures on f7 and Carlson plays f5
again this pawn is pinned from the
bishop you can't recapture Carson is
ready to open up into position and well
unfortunately for black you can't even
Castle here if you Castle this loses
terribly 2f captures on e6 you can't
block the pawn with the Queen because
the bishop is on h4 and if you play a
move like for example Queen to d8 you
get rook captures on f8 with Czech
Bishop captures and now this e 7 would
check from the bishop on c4 King h8 and
now Bishop to d3 threatening checkmate
on h7 Queen h7 checkmate so after more
like g6 simply Queen captures on g6
Queen Katherine g6 and E captures on f8
grabbing another Queen with Czech Queen
to g8 and Bishop to f6
checkmate so after f5
mr. Gruen and I played Queen to h5 we
have Bishop captures on e6 and now nice
to d7 trying to get the knight into the
game which Knight to f6 but cousin
well plays a very active but he pushes
f6 and immediately has this terrible
threat of Bishop to g4 with check
winning the Queen Knight captures and f6
is played and now Carson simply well
black doesn't really have a lot of
options here plays the rook captures on
f6 now Bishop to g4 again being a
terrible threat his opponent plays Queen
captures on h4 trying to give up the
Queen
for example Queen captures Queen and
then Jing Zhi captures rook on f6 and
although this would still be completely
winning for white after this Queen
captures on h4 move Carlsen goes for the
for the fastest immediate win and a
beautiful win as well Queen captures on
c6 with check King 37 and now wrote the
f7 with check well what you gonna play
here if you play king 38 you will
prolong the game for a couple moves but
his opponent played King captures a nice
on e6 and allows Carlsen to finish the
game with this beautiful Queen to see
for checkmate forming this beautiful
square here where the queen is
checkmating the black King and also
protecting the rook on f7 through the
King so the beautiful position so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said
Carson was 14 at the gate at the time
this game was played he won the
Norwegian championship with seven points
out of nine he had a tied first place
with Simon act this team his coach in
his earlier years but well he had more
wins in the tournaments in the
tournament even though they had the same
the same amount of points so Carlson was
awarded first place so I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon